I wrote this essay called is optimism a
scam the pure thesis behind it was what
you had 20 years ago was the secret the
book that came out it was this idea that
you could just manifest things into
reality and the cynical skeptical crowd
completely described to destroy the idea
there's three great examples of the
secrets Winston Churchill when he was 19
years old saying one day this great City
will be under attack I will be the one
that saves it 40 50 years before World
War II you have Arnold Schwarzenegger
saying I will become the greatest
bodybuilder ever and the greatest movie
star at the time John Rockefeller as
well which is one day I will be the
richest man in the world he said that to
his bank teller who like rejected him
for a bank so that's the kind of ball
case for like ridiculous affirmations
that manifest reality but the problem
with that is for every Rockefeller
Schwarzenegger Churchill there's ten
thousand delusionals that say these
things and the problem that the optimism
crowd has him it's a marketing problem
they've oversold it and the best put
down ever was Dave Chappelle where he's
saying if the secret was true why aren't
all the starving kids in Africa
manifesting food